is the s22 ultra really that much better
than the s21 and the note 20 ultra well
today we will find out because we are
going to be comparing everything from
the designs to performance of the cpu
and the graphics we're going to go over
the camera systems the displays cellular
speed and much more i have to say that
i'm so glad that samsung went back to
the note 20 design the bodies are almost
identical we have only a few differences
the sim card slot is now on the bottom
instead of the top and on the back the
camera bumps have changed now initially
i didn't really like it that much based
on images online but in person i love
the nice clean look of those lenses
being individual and then comparing to
the s21 ultra i mean who can disagree
that the s22 ultra looks so much better
than the s21 and of course the s22 ultra
has that slot for the s pen whereas the
s21 supports it but it doesn't have it
built in and another interesting change
is that the s22 has this little plastic
inserts for the 5g antenna which the
previous ones
did not have and i'm excited to test out
the speed in just a little bit and
another interesting difference is that
the display isn't as curved on the new
ultra the s22 compared to the previous
note because the frame is a lot thicker
now all three ultras have that under
display ultrasonic sensor but is the new
one better or faster let's go ahead and
see how fast these are
okay pretty much instant let's try the
screen off
very very quick and this is the note 20.
now one thing samsung has done is just
with software updates they've improved
it from when it came out
okay a little bit of delay there
very very quick and all of these are
updated
all the samsung phones let's try the new
one
very quick i can't really tell the
difference next let's go ahead and do a
speaker comparison
now dobby almost is hidden in the menus
but we did add it to all the phones and
we're making sure that it's enabled on
all of them just like in yesterday's
video and when we tested the s22 ultra
against the iphone we were a little bit
underwhelmed so let's see if it actually
does sound worse than the previous
ultras
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys wow a lot of you guys did
not believe us in our previous video but
i think we were right in our uh
conclusion you guys have to hear this
for yourselves atmos is on on both
they're both turned on
here we have which one's the new one
right here we have the s22 ultra let's
play it
hopefully you guys can hear that for
yourselves
there's a massive difference in loudness
dude that's wow yeah much quieter the
note 20
definitely is quite a bit louder when we
were recording that test it was hitting
about a decibel maybe two decibels
louder on the s21 ultra here's the s22
[Music]
that's the proof right there both of
them are turned up all the way atmos is
turned on and the s21 ultra sounds
better and is quite a bit louder this is
the best out of the bunch followed
closely with the note 20 ultra and
definitely behind is the s2 s22 ultra
now no longer a note so they definitely
had to put in worse speakers into this
phone because they upped the battery
capacity from 4 500 milliamp hours on
the note 20 ultra to 5 000 and now let's
compare the displays samsung made a huge
deal about their 1750 knit display which
is incredible so let's see how much of a
difference that makes in the real world
now in front of me i went into the
settings we have extra brightness turned
on just like in the last comparison to
the iphone and i matched up the
brightness to the top camera above and
as you can see the s22 ultra's
brightness is turned down quite a bit
lower than the other two phones and the
note 20 needs the brightness slider
turned up more so to match and now let's
see just how bright these screens can
get if we max them out manually
right wow the s22 ultra is definitely
brighter it's blowing out that top
camera let me adjust it the previous two
ultras are fairly close in brightness
when you manually turn them up whereas
the s22 ultra gets much brighter now
setting the phones to adaptive
brightness and maxing them out you see
that indoors the s22 ultra is definitely
allowing us brighter uh backlighting but
then when we go outside it is really
surprising to see that even though both
of them are maxed out the note 20 is
just as bright and direct bright
sunlight in auto mode as the new s22
ultra and then pulling out the s21 ultra
we get the same exact result the
brightness levels and direct sunlight
are basically identical now i'm not sure
what is going on maybe samsung updated
these phones to get brighter than what
they allowed before but when we compared
the s22 against the iphone and we saw
that the brightness was very similar
well now it kind of makes sense because
we're getting nowhere near that peak
1750 in its brightness outdoors it looks
more like the 1200 or so that we get
from the latest iphone
and latest samsung's now of course that
peak brightness is for hdr video so i
have all of them set to maximum
brightness as you guys could see it
won't even let me control it because the
app is controlling it and let's go ahead
and take a look at hdr video to see how
these compare and there it is we're
seeing the same thing as before
the s22 ultra at the top looks dimmer
than the rest with the note 20 ultra
interestingly looking the brightest all
the settings are the same everything's
set up exactly identically
and look at that difference in hdr the
note 20 looks the best people in our
previous video said that maybe the
iphone was just too bright in the mids
but taking a look at samsung's other
phones they are playing back hdr very
similar where you can actually see a
good amount of mid detail whereas their
latest phone really brings down the mids
and makes it look like a lot flatter of
an image now the youtube app is updated
and all of these phones they're all on
the latest version and we get this
difference in playback hopefully samsung
can fix this and update the software to
make this phone look better because
theoretically it should be brighter and
look better in every way than the what
year and a half old or so note 20 ultra
and just to add we do have the
performance and processing speed set to
maximum so with that said let's get into
performance to see how much better is
the new snapdragon 8 gen 1 compared to
the previous ones i'm running geekbench
5's cpu test here and as we can see the
s22 ultra is ahead in our iphone
comparison video some of you guys said
that the battery was a little bit low
around 15 or 18 percent that could have
hindered performance so today all three
of these are above 80 percent now so we
will get the results again all right we
have a result and this is
interesting because the multi-core
scores are almost
identical well you have what's the
difference here between eight points
over here and a couple hundred here
which is nothing this is three
generations of chips we have the 865
plus the 888 and the snapdragon one
zapper dragon 8 gen 1 but the proof is
not here now single core yes we do have
a difference the s22 ultra is 29 faster
than the note and 23 faster than the s21
so we have an improvement there in terms
of clock speeds uh but let's go ahead
and do one more test we'll do a web
browsing one we're gonna see just how
responsive these phones are and if that
single core performance really will help
day to day and here are the results the
s21 and s22 are almost identical only
five percent difference in terms of this
web browser test and the note is
actually really far behind i don't know
if that also might have to do with i
don't know ssd or maybe something else
so we do have a good difference here but
not a big difference right over here now
the big thing they hit on as far as the
new processor is actually the graphics
so let's go ahead and test that out i
have 3d marks wildlife extreme opened up
right here we are going to test the
unlimited one so we're not capped by fps
and let's hope for some bigger
differences than what we saw in the cpu
test all right guys finally
we have some good news take a look at
these scores this is an extreme test and
the s22 ultra literally has almost
double the score compared to the s21 and
the note 20 ultras these are almost
identical so you have 7.3 fps 7.6 and
then
14.4 of course is a very extreme test
but this is where we are seeing the real
games it gains in terms of gaming
performance somebody will be doing a
gaming test video uh so if you guys want
to see that make sure to subscribe but
this is really good news now the next
thing i really am curious about is the
performance of the 5g modem in this
thing we have this new antenna so let's
go ahead and put in the sim and see what
kind of speeds we get i ran each phone
individually with the same sim card on
the same settings and here are our
results now unfortunately the s21 ultra
as far as download speed is pretty much
the same as the note 20 but the upload
was quite a bit slower than both of
these
now you see the s21 killed in terms of
download speed and did the same as a
note on upload now i thought maybe this
is an issue so we actually ran this
three different times with three
different servers and the results were
identical as you guys can see so very
disappointing i'm not sure what is going
on and then we also went outside and we
compared that performance thankfully it
did get quite a bit better we're in a
concrete room here but we still got
about the same speed as far as download
compared to these and upload was
slightly faster than the note 20 but
still behind the s21
very very interesting results i don't
know if they are trying to save power
this new chipset for 5g we went through
the settings to make sure there's no low
power modes or anything like that we're
in full performance and overall well you
guys see the results for yourselves and
these ones we just tested one time and
they worked really well
so that is the 5g for you guys and now
we have to talk about the cameras of
course we have the same design as a note
20 for the s22 ultra
but we now have one extra lens a three
times lens just like the s21 ultra with
that we still have the 10 times
telescopic camera which is awesome and
the 108 megapixel
large high resolution
sensor we also have some differences
with the selfie cameras so with these
photos you guys let me know which one
looks better to you and we have
ultrawides on all of them now i am going
to be doing a detailed comparison with a
lot of images from these and it's going
to be blind style like we've done in the
past that is very fun and this gives you
guys a chance to see all the images
without knowing which phone is which and
you can vote for which one is the best
without knowing which one is the latest
one so it's fully unbiased so make sure
you guys are subscribed with
notifications enabled so you guys don't
miss out on that that will be here in
the next day or two so what are my
thoughts overall well i'm glad i went
back to this design i'm glad that unlike
the note 20 you could have the full
resolution and you can have the high
refresh rate and the battery got a
little bit larger and we have better
graphics performance but at the same
time you're spending a lot of money and
in the real world we're not seeing that
much of an improvement in performance
and we also don't have that micro sd
card slot like the note 20 offers so if
you already have a note 20 ultra i would
not upgrade the speaker sound better on
that one the 5g performs very similarly
you're not really limited and software
has been very well optimized over the
last year and a half same thing with the
s21 ultra it's hard to justify upgrading
maybe if you want that a little s pen
built in that might be worth it but you
guys let me know your thoughts with all
of these tests down below click above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]
you